work it in on Whiteside and there is the
matchup we talked about Richardson on
Trey young here comes Trey young on a
blow by kicks it back out Spelman three
overall Linux so the big fella moves
into the starting lineup for the first
time in response by hitting a
three-pointer for his first shot seven
from three crayon switched against
Olynyk
Kelly didn't fight on the pace but
couldn't stop the back pass to Spelman
and a foul on Josh Richardson basketball
Trey young will fine you look at the
kept his dribble there nice head fake
see Spellman cut into the basket off the
glass and in see it again here
nice pace is there by the young fella
see it again here nice pace is there by
the young fella and a bit Rangers in his
first quarter Tyler Johnson traffic
pressure from the heat depth on top of
the kitchen Mike Wayne definite shot it
well made it look easy
4539 Atlanta for a young double whips it
to the opposite corner and Spelman
this fall collected by Alex lamb Prince
Rory's got a dozen is that three to the
penalty so early in quarters now folk
teams will be shooting foul shots the
rest of the period Kevin let it fly
young fella just say Kevin herd has
gotten his confidence back
I mean you got will run more picking
local roads with white side if you don't
it's gonna be tough oh look at Kevin
this an assist number 10 comes right
here I mean Matt Ryan would be thrilled
to see that fence oh is that's a
pinpoint of a 23rd Porter walked by 10
ray young lobs it up right there as Alex
led to deliver ninety six ninety to
Atlanta
aux has led by as many as 15 of the
period Whitefish down to pipe just a
three point lead and we've still got a
lifetime left in this game for a young
out of a double Dorian from the
three-point land of his own